why are some cancers fast growing and some cancers
slow growing?
So the speed of replication is the speed
of the growth of the cancer.
And why is that?
Good question.
There's multiple different metabolic factors
that are taking place with a cancer.
And it really has to do with how whatever
is causing the cancer, whatever caused the cancer,
whatever damage the DNA in the first place,
what rate that replication is taking place.
And that can change through a person's cancer.
It does change constantly.
Because as you go through some treatment,
it slows the cancer growth.
And then the cancer can take off again.
And then you do something different.
It can slow the cancer growth so that it can take off again.
So that rate of replication changes.
So there's just multiple factors that affect
the close tie-in rate of apoptosis at the same time.
Because if you could be killing the cancer
that faster than it's replicating,
then you're going to be winning your battle.